[Musik]
ach du scheiße
digcker ach du scheiße und ich auch noch
mit
[Musik]
Höhenangst oh mein Gott diger mir macht
das richtig Angst gerade ich kann gar
nicht kommentieren ne e for real ich wei
also es wird bei euch nicht so rüberkmen
wie bei mir
aber oh mein oh mein Gott Bro was kommt
der so nah nimm do die Vögel mit ach du
scheiße
dicker und was mache ich jetzt
hier
ich drauf oh mein Gott oh mein Gott oh
mein Gott oh mein Gott oh mein
[Musik]
Gott oh mein Gott dicker ich stand doch
noch drauf da oben stand ich einfach
gerade wir schauen uns das nochal
[Musik]
an eine Stunde später okay
Freunde ich glaube wir haben hier gar
keine richtige Aufgabe ich habe das vor
ein paar Jahren schon mal gemacht aber
in deutlich schlechterer Qualität und
mit einer ganz anderen beschisseneren VR
Brille ich glaube allerdings dass wir
hier gar keine Aufgabe
haben also jetzt nichts einsammeln
müssen wir können das quasi einfach
erleben und wenn ich jetzt nach vorne
spring
oh ja okay wenn man mit der Tatsache
rangt dass man dass man runter springt
nimmt es einem die Angst und den
übelkeitseffekt mir ist halt das Problem
dass ich Höhenangst habe und mir schnell
schlecht wird und würde ich sagen wir am
Boden sind wir schon machen jetzt mal
die himmelsmalerei habe ich gerade zwei
Knöpfe auf einmal gedrückt na ja das war
uns mal
[Musik]
überraschen das
denn no
way no way ich
kann ich kann durch die Stadt
fliegen was geht den jetzt ab Anmerkung
aus dem Schnitt alles was nicht gut
befestigt ist Alter wir fliegen er ganz
oben oh guck mal ich mal eine spurter
mir her Wahnsinn kann ich in das Ding
hier
[Musik]
reinfliegen
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht ob ich
überhaupt noch höher oh
wow doch ich bin schon noch mal ein
Stück höher
geflogen
diger was geht hier denn ab tatsächlich
wahrscheinlich immer noch das was nicht
gut befestigt ist okay ich glaube ich
bin maximum angekommen weil das hier
irgendwie nicht mehr weiter nach oben
geht obwohl ich noch oben zeige aber
schaut euch das mal
an ich bin am höchsten Punkt komme ich
jetzt irgendwie wieder
runter nee ich muss jetzt
h
ach dicker ich muss den kompletten Weg
wieder runterfliegen zwei Tage später so
Freunde da sind wir jetzt auch schon
beim Aufzug
ange ach ich muss noch da
äh
boah gebt euch mal wie weit oben ich war
da ganz oben war ich einfach aber okay
gut gehen wir noch ein stockwg tiefer
das krasse ist halt echt dass das
einfach dafür gemacht ist dass man
überall rumfliegen kann ich finde so
Spiele müssen auch gar nicht so krass
von der Grafik sein sowas reicht mir ja
komplett einfach wenn man eine coole
erlebnissache hier hat vor allem mit
einer vrbrille ist ist halt irre wow
okay machen wir mal Lanke noch mal da
kam nämlich gerade
das
hallo perfekt diger wenn man hier oben
bei der Planke angekommen ist kann man
sagen ob man nur die Planke haben möchte
oder Torte Donuts oder
spinnentorte ist den eine
spinnentorte was hat das denn mit
Spinnen zu
tun oder bin ich
jetzt ver tu ich mich hier
gerade oh mein Gott oh mein
[Musik]
Gott ich h
was oh mein Gott nein
ne oh mein Gott ich habe panische Angst
vor
Spinnen oh mein Gott
[Musik]
wir machen das nicht Mitte Spinnen oh
mein Gott ich ma da kam noch
eine da ist schon wieder diese Torte ich
vertraue dem ganzen Scheiß nicht wir
machen was anderes machen heldenakademie
Bo ich bin raus mit Spinnen ne ich hasse
Spinnen wie die P ich krieg direkt
Herzrasen schweißig schitzig ich kann
ich kann nicht mehr reden Bo
Feer warum könnt ihr das nicht normal
einchreiben
oh boah ich bin krass au ich bin noch
nicht krass ich bin häen geblieben ich
bin ich muss doch zurück ich muss hier
lang
diger
komm komm junge
für
Deutschland um die Kurve hier
runter
hoch hier rein und der Fassade oh mein
Gott oh mein Gott ich muss kotzen glaube
ich mir geh so schlechtow hier oben
durch und runter runter wo wo wo ist es
wo ist da hier durch habe ich geschafft
ich hab geschafft hier durch noch mal
durch hochus klar W lang auch sonst hier
oben ich stell neen Weltrekord auf ich
sag's euch hier oben durch
und jetzt nach ganz oben durchziiel doch
nicht wieder runter links hier lang mir
wird so schlecht ich hab's gewonnen ich
hab es geschafft hier ist das Ziel B
diger Strafen für verpasste Checkpoint
ich habe keinen einzigen Checkpoint
verpasst du Bastard was muss ich denn
jetzt machen ach nein da kommen Raketen
auf New York geflogen e digcker was ist
denn das den Spiel ich dasüber eine
Planke ne zack die haben ne die haben
wir noch nicht doch haben wir auch da
hinten kommt noch eine dicker wo ich bin
jetzt hier einfach dem Kriegsgebiet
gelandet Rakete gegen
Rakete e m es macht schon bisschen Angst
ne hier vorne fliegt mir ein bisschen zu
nah um die Hochhäuser rum wir schneiden
allerdings den Weg ab boah perfekt
gemacht und jetzt von der Seite nein oh
mein Gott ich sag euch das ist mit der
Brille macht das so viel Spaß hier
gerade W nicht den die Rakete mal
erwischen wird diger wieso ist die blö
die so schnell Alter ja wie soll ich die
denn erwischen
Putz hat gerettet zwei Sterne guck mal
da drin bin ich gut ach perfekt ja hab
die Stadt gerettet sieht man